thank you very much for joining us when
you're a little under the weather I
think you've got a bit of a cold well
I'm rebounding Matt but great to be with
you good to see you all it's great to
have you here I also want to make sure I
welcome our audiences who are joining us
on Twitter wsj.com and YouTube so we've
got a lot to get to let's start with
Ukraine
the day started today with two
explosions that happened deep in Russian
territory which is the latest indication
that the ukrainians seem capable of
striking
deep inside Russia can you tell us
anything about what happened and how do
you feel about it from the American
point of view when the ukrainians do
things like that well Matt I've
obviously seen those reports
um I don't have anything further to add
to it except this
um every single day
um we are seeing
explosions across the entirety of
Ukraine
as Russia tries to take out its energy
infrastructure that's the current
reality in Ukraine that's what's
happening as I said quite literally
every day and I do want to talk about
that but I just I want to just to stick
to this point for a woman that we
reported today that the U.S has modified
the high Mars a bit to prevent some
long-range firing clearly there's a U.S
concern of escalation you're trying to
manage work with the ukrainians but How
concerned in general are you even as the
situation plays out we'll talk about
Ukraine in a second about the escalation
risk at this point our focus is on
continue to do what we've been doing
which is to make sure that Ukraine has
in its hands what it needs to defend
itself what it needs to push back
against the Russian aggression to take
back territory that's been seized from
it since February 24th to make sure as
well that it has the support
economically and on a humanitarian basis
to withstand what's happening to the
country every single day that's our
focus and let's let's talk about the
Ukrainian objective for right now I
think a few months ago if I remember
right I heard you and Jake Sullivan were
talking at that point that part of what
needed to happen for the ukrainians was
to get as much land as possible before
the winter arrived to try to maximize
their position on the battlefield
winter's now here the ukrainians
obviously have made great gains from
here on out what's the Ukrainian
objective ultimately in terms of
territory is it really realistic to
think about the ukrainians pushing back
in Crimea what where are they right now
first most important thing is this as
the president said consistently
for us the number one principle is
nothing about Ukraine without Ukraine
and that means that fundamentally
ukrainians are making the decisions
about where they want to go where they
want to go where when they want to get
there how they want to do it but with
our support and support of dozens of
countries around the world
to flip the question for a second let's
look at what Russia's been trying to do
because that will also tell you where
Ukraine's trying to go first Russia
tried to in effect erase Ukraine's
identity as an independent country to
subsume it back into Russia that was
Putin's self-described number one
objective that's failed and it won't
succeed
um then they engaged in a land grab to
get as much as they could in eastern and
southern Ukraine that too is now failing
as we've seen the Ukrainian since the
summer push back uh in an increasingly
effective way so the current objective
is to take the war to the Ukrainian
people Putin is directing his his ire
and his fire at Ukrainian civilians
trying to take out the energy
infrastructure to turn off the heat the
water the lights especially as Ukraine
has into winter so the primary challenge
now for Ukraine is to resist that and of
course to continue what they're doing
which is to get back the land that's
been seized and I do and I do want to
talk about the Russians but just to push
on this point a bit
you know uh the support in America I
think has been strong I think the
administration is happy with the
strength of that support the alliance
has held together well as we'll discuss
but when you when you indicate the
ukrainians can you know are the really
one of the ones to set the agenda does
that suggest open-ended U.S commitment
for Ukraine no matter where they want to
go even if that means go into Ukraine
can we afford and support to do that or
realistically is there some limit here
and do the ukrainians know that
fundamentally they have to make these
decisions and they have to make sure
that they're making informed decisions
based on what their capacity is what it
can be to achieve their objectives but
it's fundamentally up to the ukrainians
we're committed to supporting them uh
not just us get up to the end of
wherever they want to take I just came
back from from NATO meetings in Romania
and before and on the margins of that G7
meetings the president of course has had
had many and I can tell you the
commitment to Ukraine to helping Ukraine
defend itself to helping Ukraine deal
with the Russian aggression to helping
Ukraine get back territory that was
seized from it to supporting it on a
humanitarian basis to support it
economically that commitment is strong
it's robust and it's Europe and its
countries well beyond Europe too okay
well I'll get to the let's talk about
Russia now and to be clear I think in
the weekend you even described their
actions as barbaric in terms of their
targeting of civilians and civilian
infrastructure is that is that the core
russian strategy now is this did they
fail on the battlefield and now
the core russian approach is to go at
civilian civilian areas in hopes of what
eroding the war do you expect them to
make a strong presence on the
battlefield again at some point or has
is this a fundamental script a shift in
their strategy keep in mind the
battlefield is still there I understand
it's still acute but in a sense what
they've tried to do is extend it to the
entire country and and focus on
civilians not just the Ukrainian
military so we have these front lines in
eastern and southern Ukraine there
hasn't been a tremendous amount of
movement since the
very significant recapture of Carson by
the by the Ukrainian forces
so yes the strategy is to try to take it
to the Ukrainian civilians and in effect
to get them to cry uncle
it's not going to work
um now having said that there's
tremendous suffering that's going along
with that and when you're seeing again
as you're heading into winter uh Jen
stoltenberg the Secretary General of
NATO called this the the weaponization
of winter that's the effort made by the
Russians now but there's something else
happening just as we've been working in
a very effective and coordinated fashion
with dozens of countries to make sure
that we were getting the ukrainians the
defensive equipment that they need the
weapons that they need to defend
themselves we're doing the same thing on
on the energy side of the equation
working in a coordinated way through the
G7 in coordination with the European
Union in coordination with the World
Bank evrd and others to try to make sure
that they have the resources as
necessary to repair and to replace the
components of their electric grid that
are being destroyed by by real time as
fast as you can in real time yes it's
fast as we can how do you assess the
Russian military right now there are
some rumors of another maybe even a
bigger mobilization coming in in January
uh how strong or weak are they at this
moment look I think others can opine on
that with um uh greater expertise than I
can Lloyd Austin Mark Billy and others
but I think what we've seen is this
we've seen a massive mobilization this
summer 300 000 not all of that has
actually been fully mobilized probably
about about a third but what happens you
get forces that are barely trained
poorly equipped not winterized who are
thrown into this mix and it's terrible
but they're also not generally speaking
particularly effective units
even as they mobilized or in the midst
of mobilizing 300 000 people there's
another side of the story
since February 24th well over a million
Russians have left their country some to
escape potential mobilizations others
because this is not generally what they
want to live with that is terrible for
Russia and for its Future these tend to
be among the the most educated and
contributing members of society
particularly to their to their economy
they're gone that's going to have a
devastating impact on Russia going
forward and that raises a question that
I know you've been asked 100 times I
think I might even ask you this once or
twice which is but but we're now almost
a year in so so maybe the answer has
changed is there still
any off-ramp for the Russians is there
any even Whisper of negotiations or any
kind of discussion that could lead to
negotiations right now that could you
know somehow resolve the situation for
the moment is there anything that you
see out there well in a sense there's
there's always an off ramp and it's very
simple
President Putin started this war he
could end it tomorrow yeah but really
realistically though it's a situation
where that's not it doesn't seem to be a
realistic option in his mind
president zelinski said we've said
others have said that at some point this
will end and it will end almost
certainly with diplomacy with a
negotiation but
what I think we have to see
is a just and durable peace not a phony
piece and by that I mean this
um
if Russia doesn't succeed in its current
Gambit of trying to um
in effect get the Ukrainian people to
throw up their hands and again they
won't succeed I think the resilience of
ukrainians has been extraordinary and
and fundamentally the reason that they
won't succeed is the ukrainians are
fighting for their land for their
country for their future the Russians
are not and that's the biggest
difference maker of all with some
significant help but one of the things
that you can imagine is
the Russians trying to find an off-ramp
that would be a phony off-ramp by which
I mean oh let's have a ceasefire let's
just freeze things in place get a frozen
conflict never negotiate about the
territory that they have seized and
continue to hold
rest refit regroup re-attack
I think it's important so you're not
that you're saying that's not something
the U.S could really support you I think
Korea you had a ceasefire in a sense you
never really you know again
fundamentally fundamentally this is up
to the ukrainians but I think and you've
heard president zielinski put forward
a 10-point proposal for how this can
move forward and zielinski himself has
said diplomacy negotiations will be at
the end of this what's happened as he
was saying that he put this before the
G20 just a few weeks ago as he was
saying that
Putin doubled and tripled down on what
he was doing in Ukraine so the point is
this
unless and until Russia demonstrates
that it's interested in meaningful
diplomacy it can't go anywhere if and
when it does
will be the first to be ready to help
out when we talk about barbaric acts
when you talk about the Russians
attacking the civilians and use quite
strong words about it
you know there's a lot of things that
have been said that are sort of a
predicate for war crimes here so at the
end of whenever that resolution moment
comes how do we deal with
all these acts all these things that the
administration and ukrainians say are
atrocities and and how can the world
possibly manage that look it's very
important that there be accountability
for what's happened what's happening
right now
is that in a variety of ways the
information the evidence is being
collected for war crimes the ukrainians
are doing it themselves are heading
toward indictments heading towards
something I don't want to prejudge where
this is going but it's important that
this information be collected it's
important that Ukraine be able to as
necessary prosecute these things but
we're also supporting the efforts of the
international criminal court to collect
evidence and information there's been
discussion of some kind of Independent
Court or tribunal being established I
think all of that's on the table and at
some point it's going to be very
important it's on the table that sounds
like it also could be part of
negotiations potentially look I don't
want to prejudge it but all I can say is
this
accountability for what's happened is
very important okay we do talk to the
Russians I know on and off and I just
want to quickly ask before I go on there
continue to be persistent rumors about
Brittany Greiner coming home some deal
can you give us any update on
negotiations on that situation
Matt what I can say is this
um as I think is well known we put
um a significant proposal on the table
some months ago now and since then we've
had other conversations other
engagements
and we are constantly looking
and how we can bring Americans who in
One Way or Another being arbitrarily
detained whether it's in Russia or
anywhere else to get them home that's
one of my number one responsibilities uh
in Russia
Brittany Greiner you've got Paul Whelan
but again this is happening in countries
um around around the world and it is a
constant effort on the part of the state
department on the part of the government
to find ways to bring them home so we've
been we've been engaged with them other
than that I don't think it's useful for
me to have the details
um let's talk about another uh side
effect of the uh of the war which is our
relations with the Europeans you spent
the day with the Europeans I think
president macron was here last week that
mood music was very very positive but he
and others in Europe do seem rather
concerned about not just their own
energy situation but about uh the uh the
inflation reduction act the idea that
it's going to suck a lot of resources
away from Europe the president has
suggested he's open to modifying how we
apply that to address the concerns but
but he didn't give any details can you
elaborate on on what the administration
might do here well first thing to say is
this
on
just about all of the issues that matter
most we've just been talking about
Russia and Ukraine we may have probably
have a word or two about China at some
point but across the board what I've
seen over the past couple of years is a
growing and ever deeper convergence
between the United States and Europe
including the European Union on these
issues and one of the things that we
established to help build that
convergence is this trade and Technology
Council not for the third time today and
Gina raimondo Catherine Thai our
colleagues from the European commission
commissioner vestiger and bronchus we
met and we continue to build that
convergence and what did you hear from
them what we heard from them two things
first I think there's a recognition that
the inflation reduction act represents
the single biggest commitment to dealing
effectively with climate change than
we've ever seen and that that actually
Advance as a shared objective because
both the United States and the European
Union want to move in that direction and
we need to have the resources to do it
the IRA does exactly that
second I think a recognition that there
are immense benefits flowing from it
for everyone whether whatever side of
the Atlantic you're on having said that
we know that the Europeans have concerns
about specific aspects of the IRA those
concerns were raised when it first
became law we almost immediately
established a task force between the
United States and the European Union to
work through those concerns when
President macron is here he and
President Biden discussed them and what
the president said was this we will work
to address through this task force the
concerns that you have to see where we
can do things that will effectively
address them the conversation we had
today among other things touched on the
electric vehicle tax credit that it
touched on the commercial vehicle tax
credit it touched on how we can work
better together on critical minerals and
I'm confident based on those
conversations and based on the work of
the task force that we will be able and
and relatively quickly get to a place
that addresses some of these and share
some thoughts on model applications and
and and where you'll go that's got
that's coming another look I don't want
to yeah and I don't want to get ahead of
those conversations but those
conversations are active and uh we're
committed to working on it okay you
ruined my surprise on China uh uh but
let's let's talk a little bit about
China
um
I can't tell if the coven protests have
died down entirely I don't know if you
have a view but but but in general what
do these protests tell the White House
about uh XI xinping's uh popularity at
home right now what did you learn from
them look it's it's
hard for us and in a sense not
appropriate for us to opine on what's
going on internally in China other than
to say this
um
whether it's China whether it's Iran
whether it's anywhere else we stand
strongly for the proposition that people
should be allowed to voice their
opinions to protest peacefully to make
their own their views and that
governments should not take action well
it's interesting because in both those
cases it's hard to tell but it does seem
that the governments have responded in
some ways to both of those there are
indications of that but
um I think it is a little bit too soon
to tell it appears that China's relaxed
some of its coveted protocols and on the
Iranian side of the equation there have
been reports of the disband of the
morality police although we've seen
contrary reports but the other thing
I'll say is this about China
we want China to get coveted right it's
profoundly in our interest that that
happened uh it's in the interests of uh
the Chinese people first and foremost
but it's also in the interests of people
around the world so we want them to
succeed uh we've seen the uh dramatic
impact that the slowing of China's
economy as a resultant part of the the
shutdown for covet is having not just in
China but around the world that's in no
one's interests so our hope is that they
find a way to move forward and move
forward in a way that addresses the uh
the challenge
um we're about a month out I think from
uh when the president and Xi Jinping met
in Mali you're heading uh to China I
think early next month as a kind of a
follow-up trip the meeting seemed in
some ways just aimed at putting a floor
under relations right now
have you seen any change any shift any
development since that meeting
any progress of the relationship do you
think overall what are you seeing look
this is this is a process but it's very
important for us
as you say Matt to have a floor under
the relationship to make sure that we
have lines of communication that are are
active across different levels of the
government to make sure that we're being
very clear with each other about what
we're doing and why we're doing it and
it's not just important to us it's
important to countries around the world
one of the things that I hear again and
again is I'm traveling around is an
expectation from countries around the
world that China and the United States
responsibly manage this this
relationship we're determined to do that
we're determined to stand up very
clearly and strongly for our own
interests and values there's no no
surprise
at the same time
it's important to us to see if we can
find ways to cooperate on issues that
affect both of our countries but also
affect countries around the world
whether it's climate whether it's Global
Health whether it's macroeconomics we'll
see if we can do that but the most
important thing is to make sure that
we're responsibly managing the
relationship we're in an intense
competition we don't want it to Veer
into conflict well the biggest risk
there is probably Taiwan so let's get a
couple quick questions and we can turn
to questions from the audience in a
second but is it a good idea for a
republican speaker of the house to go to
Taiwan after speaker Pelosi went a few
months ago look what's happening here
and what's happening with Taiwan at
least in my judgment and our judgment is
this
um
we would like to see the status quo
preserved and by status quo I mean this
for decades
the United States and China have
actually responsibly managed the
challenge of Taiwan and we've managed it
through the one China policy the uh the
three communiques the six assurances the
Taiwan Relations Act and at the heart
of that is an understanding that the
differences between Taiwan and Beijing
are going to be resolved peacefully
and that we have us have a strong stake
in security and stability across the
Taiwan Strait well you say peacefully
but you also have said recently I
believe that you think the Chinese have
moved up their timetable for Taiwan it
it seems to me that several secretaries
of State have said to me pretty directly
one way or another they think the
Chinese are determined
to re-emerge with Taiwan or merge with
Taiwan either peacefully or unpeacefully
that that is the goal is it we do we
fundamentally believe the United States
that come hell or high water that's what
they want to do here
I think what we've seen in recent years
is
China moving away
from an understanding that the status
quo is what needs to be preserved and to
exert increasing pressure on Taiwan to
um
move things in the direction that China
wants can you move the Chinese back on
that do you think look one of the things
that's important is this is again as I'm
going around the world and talking to
many other countries
this stake in peace and stability across
the Taiwan Strait it's not just a
profound interest that we have it's a
profound interest of virtually every
country around the world why
50 of the container traffic in the world
goes through the straight every single
day
if you're looking of course at
microchips it's semiconductors a vast
majority of those chips are produced
right now in Taiwan if there were to be
a crisis which is of course the very
thing that we want to avert the impact
on countries around the world the impact
on the world economy
could be devastating so I think what
China is hearing from other countries
not just us is that
there shouldn't be yeah they're getting
that message there should not be
unilateral steps to change the status
quo so you you think that they are
getting that message well certainly I'm
hearing this from other countries and I
suspect that uh China is too and you
sorry but to come back to it it's a good
idea for a republican speaker of the
house to go to Taiwan then now look
um
Congress is an independent co-equal
branch of government
okay fair enough I I do want to take a
question but we mentioned Iran I'd still
have to get to a couple quick things I
have to ask very quickly you mentioned
the protest realistically
[Music]
is the nuclear deal
on life support at this point I mean I
think technically it's open but I don't
think anything is happening the Iranians
are talking about enriching more uranium
when when do you when do you call it
well two things
first taking a step back
when the nuclear deal was enforced the
so-called jcpoa
it succeeded in its objective which was
putting Iran's nuclear program in a box
and it's very unfortunate that we pulled
out of that deal which has allowed Iran
to use it as an excuse to get back out
of the box
when the deal was in force Iran was
making good on its commitments that's
not just me saying it it's independent
International experts in fact it's the
state department under the previous
administration
um when the deal was enforced Iran's
breakout time that is the time it would
be required for it to produce enough
fissile material for one nuclear weapon
had been pushed Beyond one year now it's
a matter of weeks so in and of itself
that's a very unfortunate development
having said that I think the world's
Focus right now is very much on the the
protests that are going on in Iran ever
since the killing of um what do they
tell you about the the stability of the
government right now well I think what
they tell us is this
um
they tell us that the Iranian people
want to be able to speak up and speak
out about the issues that they care
about
they tell us that the regime is afraid
to let that happen and is repressing
their efforts to do just that to be able
to say
um where they want the country to go to
be able to say what they what they want
to wear
and that to me is a sign of a weakness
not strength having said that I'm not
going to make any predictions about
where this goes you know we haven't had
diplomatic relations with Iran for a
long time our own visibility and
understanding of uh the uh the country
of the society is
um as a result uh less than it might be
but fundamentally this is about the
Iranian people it's not about us one of
the big mistakes that the regime makes
is when it sees protests is saying
whether it believes it or not that
they're being instigated by the United
States by some outside power that's a
profound misunderstanding of their own
people and their own country so the
question now is to what extent the
regime responds to the uh the needs the
aspirations the desires of their own
people
okay secretary blanket everybody I'm
afraid we're out of time out with that
but I had felt like we had to get there
so I really appreciate your candor and
being here thank you very much I want to
thank our audiences on Twitter and
wsu.com thanks man thank you all thank
you
thanks